[Music]
welcome to session 7 24 in the worlds of
speculative fiction I'll tell you a
little bit about this series just in
case you're new to it in just a moment
but I don't want to delay telling you
who we are going to be looking at and
which books in particular so it's NK
gemson a living author and these are
fairly recent Works we're looking at the
broken Earth Trilogy very imaginative
worldbuilding philosophical theme
introducing books right here um Each of
which is quite meaty and substantive and
a lot of fun to read and quite
thought-provoking so we have the fifth
season the first in the series we have
the Obelisk gate the second in the
series and then we have the stone Sky II
in the series and Al together they
comprise this really interesting epic
with lots of different characters
playing a role including the same
character viewed from different
perspectives as we'll we'll talk about
just a little bit later on so what is
Worlds of speculative fiction this is a
monthly series that we have been running
since
2016 it was originally held at the
Brookfield public Public Library who
gave us space a lot of people became
regulars and would come we've got video
recordings of every single session so
you can go back and check them out if
you want to and after the first year I
was invited back to continue the series
and originally I did it so that I could
do some guilty pleasure reading of
Science Fiction and Fantasy authors who
I had really enjoyed back in my
childhood my teens my 20s but I hadn't
read for quite a long
time and as the sessions went on I
started getting some great feedback from
people and they began suggesting who I
should tackle next and so I Incorporated
their ideas into it now when coid hit we
switched to this format after taking a
couple months off to you might say find
our way we now do this online I present
for anywhere from 9 90 to 120 minutes
and then we have a zoom session
afterwards where we can have some fairly
intimate conversation but while this is
running you see that there is a live
chat that you can write your comments in
questions try to keep them on topic
because we want to discuss these
particular works and the World building
and the key themes involved in them for
new Authors that is new to the series we
typically spend some time doing a little
bit of biography we also will look at if
they're available the things that the
authors themselves have to say about
their own work and in gems's case we
have quite a bit of that and the
emphasis on the series or the emphasis
in the series rather is on World
building and there's a ton of that going
on in these novels and on important
philosophical themes which might be
metaphysical they might be ethical they
might be epistemological they might have
to do with philosophy of
Technology action mind all these things
that fall within the range of philosophy
why do we do that because I'm a
philosopher and so I'm particularly
interested in that but I think that you
will get a richer experience out of
reading these works knowing some of the
philosophical antecedence and uh
analogies and themes that are woven into
them so we will be jumping into this
I'll talk a bit about the World building
first I think just to wet your whistle
and maybe a little bit about character
and perspective that his point of view
in these stories because that's rather
unusual as well then we'll look at gon's
biography things she has to say about
herself and then we will jump right into
a more robust examination of the world
and the important
philosophical themes that are uh
explored assumed
referenced you know other ways of
bringing them up within these three very
interesting novels before we do that I
have to say word of thanks to my friend
uh Joanne who is somebody who was there
for the Brookfield Public Library
sessions has continued on uh in our
online format and she is the one who for
several years was suggesting you gotta
read NK gemson and you gotta read the
broken Earth series and I'd say yeah
yeah okay I I'll get to that we had it
lined up to do last year but we didn't
actually get to it and so we are doing
it this year and I got to say um and I'm
going to speak directly to the camera on
this one Joanne thanks so much for
persisting in suggesting gemson and
specifically this series to me uh as so
often you are completely right it is
great great work I can't wait to talk
talk about it here and to explore it
further in discussion with whoever wants
to engage in that after this video
premieres so that is the the thanks the
you know uh shout out you could say to a
good friend of mine who is very
interested just as interested as I am
perhaps even more so in speculative
fiction and who's been a great guide
this entire time so sit back um and
enjoy we've got a lot of discussion to
to go through but feel free to leave
your comments and I'll respond to them
in the live chat if you're watching this
afterwards you can leave comments and
I'll respond to those in the normal
comments section so with no further Ado
let's get
started enk Jon's broken urge Trilogy is
presenting us with an
incredibly Rich world that she has built
and allowed to develop out of her
thoughts as we'll we'll find out later
on when we look at some of the
interviews and I think that we have to
begin with at least a summary view of
what kind of world this actually is in a
number of different important respects
going from geology itself to social
organization and you know thinking about
the roles individuals can play Within
this in in this vast story and you know
when I went back to the fifth season um
you know it's very easy to forget where
you started in the book and so I think
there's some great passages in this
prologue that tell us quite a bit about
this world so she says let's start with
the end of the world why don't we now
why begin with the end of the world
because they are going into one of the
fifth seasons in some of this book and
actually parts of it are happening later
on when the fifth season has already
begun so what is a fifth season you're
accustomed to thinking of our Four
Seasons you know winter spring summer
fall in an endless sequence a fifth
season is this incredibly
disruptive uh cataclysmic event that
makes uh it possible for human life to
be entirely wiped out from the planet
and we're actually going to find uh in
the end of the the story in the the
stone Sky uh an appendix which charts
out the different seasons um and by the
way the
the obelis gate and the stone sky are
mostly except for flashbacks taking
place in this new Fifth Season that is
going to happen so a fifth season uh
happening in the world on this continent
which is called the Stillness and so we
should begin um where she begins so enk
jemson on the first page of the prologue
says here is a land it's ordinary as
lands go mountains and plateaus and
canyons and river deltas as usual
ordinary except for its size and its
dynamism it moves a lot this land like
an old man lying restlessly AB bed it
heaves and size puckers and farts yawns
and swallows naturally this land's
people have named it the Stillness it is
a land of quiet and bitter irony the
Stillness has had other names it was
once several other lands it's one vast
unbroken continent at present but at
some point in the future it'll be more
than one again very soon now actually
and she says the end begins in a city
the oldest largest and most magnificent
living city in the world that's a very
important point and actually let me just
pause on that for a moment one of the
terms that gets used quite a bit is dead
meaning a former
civilization that may have actually been
more technologically advanced than the
current uh civilization that they're
living in but which has died because of
one of the fifth
seasons and not being able to sustain
itself over time and human race didn't
die out but all of these artifacts are
left behind so um menus is at the time
that that this is being uh sort of
written uh or being narrated it's the
greatest city in the world but it is not
the greatest City the world has ever
seen all right back to her
depiction this city is called um menis
and once it was the heart of an Empire
it is still the heart of many things
though the Empire is wilted somewhat in
the years since its first Bloom as
Empires do UMES is not unique because of
its size there are many large cities in
this part of the world chain linked
across the equator like a continental
girdle elsewhere in the world Villages
rarely grow into towns and towns rarely
become cities because all such poity
are hard to keep alive when the earth
keeps trying to eat them but yenis has
been stable for most of its 27 centuries
um menis is unique because here alone
have human beings dared to build not for
safety not for Comfort not even for
beauty but for bravery the city's walls
are a Masterwork of delicate mosaics and
embossing detailing its people's long
and brutal history the clumping masses
of its buildings are punctuated by great
High Towers like fingers of stone hand
rot lanterns powered by the Modern
Marvel of
hydroelectricity delicate delicately
arching Bridges woven of glass and
audacity and Architectural structures
called balconies that are so simple yet
so breathtakingly foolish that no one
has ever built them before in written
history but much of history is Unwritten
remember this the streets are not paved
with easy to replace cobbles but with a
smooth unbroken and miraculous substance
the locals have dubbed asphalt even the
shanties of umen are daring because
they're just thin walled Shacks that
would blow over in a bad Windstorm let
alone a shake yet they stand as they
have for Generations at the core of the
city are many tall buildings so it is
perhaps unsurprising one of them is
larger and more daring than all the rest
combined a massive structure whose base
is a star pyramid of precision carved
obsidian brick pyramids are the most
stable architectural form this one is
pyramids Time 5 because why not and and
because this is um menis a vast geodesic
sphere whose faceted walls resemble
translucent Amber sits at the pyramids
Apex seeming to balance there lightly
though it's truth every part of the
structure is channeled towards the sole
purpose of supporting it it looks
precarious that's all that matters the
Black Star is where the leaders of the
Empire meet to do their leader things
and there will actually be an entire
cast devoted to
leadership the Amber sphere is where
they keep their emperor carefully
preserved and perfect he wanders its
golden halls in Gentile despair doing
what he's told and dreading the day his
Masters decide his daughter makes a
better ornament none of these places or
people matter by the way I simply Point
them out for
context so she's giving us a flavor of
this land and I'm going to skip forward
a little bit right and there's this uh
meeting with a stone eater we're going
to talk more about them in uh a little
bit um Stone eaters rarely bother
stating the obvious you know she
mentions here and um what is is going to
be happening here so the world is going
to end because of what somebody's
doing and we get a depiction of this
here is the Stillness which is not still
even on a good day now it Ripples
reverberates and cataclysm now there is
a line roughly East West and two
straight almost neat in its manifest
unnaturalness spanning the girth of the
lands Equator the line's origin point is
the city of yenes the line is deep and
raw a cut to the quick of the planet
magma wells in its wake fresh and
glowing red the Earth is good at healing
itself the wound will scab over quickly
in geologic terms and then the cleansing
ocean will follow its line to bisect the
Stillness into two lands
until this happens the wound will Fester
with not only heat but gas and gritty
dark ash enough to choke off the sky
across most of the Stillness is face
within a few weeks plants everywhere
will die the animals that depend on them
will starve and the animals that eat
those will starve winter will come early
and hard and it will last a long long
time it will end of course like every
winter does and then the world will
return to its old self
eventually the people people of the
Stillness live in a Perpetual state of
disaster preparedness they've built
walls and dug Wells and put away food
and can easily last 5 10 even 25 years
in a world without sun eventually
meaning in this case in a few thousand
years so this is really quite important
um each of the communities what they
they call a
Comm has to revert to a different kind
of status they have to make sure that
they can sustain their population that
they can battle against other comms for
resources that become scarce during the
middle of a season everybody has to hang
together and there are of course
traitors there are of course people who
sell others out in this broken dangerous
land that turns against them and these
people think of Father Earth not Mother
Earth father Earth as being evil they
personify the Earth as something like a
god below who hates
humanity and here is where we get
introduced to one of the key ideas so
how could somebody actually break the
land himself it's going to turn out to
be Alabaster one of the main characters
because he is an origin or as they're
called derogatorily Rogas and these are
people who have the power to do things
with the Earth and as it turns out not
just the Earth but also water and air
and all sorts of other things they have
an organ a sespan in the back of their
their brain that allows them to to do
these sorts of things and they are hated
and feared by the rest of the population
what are called The Stills as opposed to
the origins and quite often they are
lynched they are butchered they are
massacred they are discriminated against
they are hated they are driven out of
their their communities and there is a
safer place for them relatively safe
called the fulcrum which is kind of a
school but as we're going to see it's
it's more than just a a school so we've
got um this very interesting
civilization that has spread across an
entire
continent um and you know they're
progressing technologically as we see
but they are beset by many problems one
of the biggest of which is the world the
Earth itself that they live upon let's
move on to one other really important
feature becomes more and more important
when you first read it you're like this
is interesting but what's going on with
this while we're doing things
continentally planetar we should
consider the OB obelisks which float
Above This the obelisks had other names
once back when they were first built and
deployed in use but nobody remembers
those names or the great devic's purpose
memories are as fragile as slate in the
Stillness in fact no one these days no
one really pays much attention to the
things at all though they're huge and
beautiful and a little terrifying
massive crystalline shards that hover
amid the clouds rotating slowly and
drifting along incomprehensible flight
paths blurring now and again as as if
they're not quite real though this may
only be a trick of the light it's
obvious that the obelisks are nothing
natural it's equally obvious they're
irrelevant awesome but purposeless just
another grave marker of just another
civilization successfully destroyed by
father Earth's TIR tireless efforts
there's many such other KS around the
world a thousand ruined cities a million
monuments to heroes or Gods no one
remembers several dozen Bridges to
Nowhere such things are not to be
admired
goes the current wisdom in the Stillness
the people who built those old things
were weak and died as the weak is the
weak inevitably must most damning is
that they failed the ones who built the
obelisks just failed harder than most
now we're not going to actually know
what she means by that until we get
really into the third book uh it's a
preent phrase right there so these these
are um some important features of the
world as we find it but we we have to
say more about what's going on so the
the Rogas the origens right they
actually can serve an important purpose
if they can be taught if they can be
tamed if they can be
harnessed you know they can help to
stabilize this world that people are
trying to live in but they're always
considered to be dangerous so everybody
else distrusts them and just to give you
an idea of something that's that's going
on in this world um we have uh sine and
alabaster these two really important
characters traveling along and uh
Alabaster is going to introduce her to
what the node Resto the node maintainers
are really doing right so let me um read
a little bit to you here um rusted
wreaking Earth High roads are dull most
people think their death traps waiting
to be sprung despite the fact that
they're usually safer than ordinary
roads all Imperial roads were built by
the teams of the best geoengineers and
Origins deliberately placed only in
locations deemed permanently stable some
of them have survived multiple Seasons
so for days at a time sine and alabaster
encounter only hard driving Merchant
caravaners mail post Riders and the
local court and patrol all of whom give
sanite and alabaster the eye upon
noticing their black fulcrum uniforms
and do not Dain to speak to them there
are few comms lining the roots turnoff
and almost no shops at which to buy
supplies though there are regular
platforms along the road itself with
prepared areas and lean toos for camping
C spent every evening swatting bugs
beside a fire with nothing to do but
glare at Alabaster and have sex with him
but that only kills a few minutes
they're actually like being placed
together to create uh super origin
children because Alabaster is a ten
ringer meaning the highest rank that you
can be so they go
on and um sayin asks what are you doing
that for uh after she noticed him
quelling micro shakes so as they're
traveling along they can feel what's
going on in the earth and they can
amplify it they can redirect it they can
quell it as Alabaster is doing uh he's
done it just again now while they wait
for dinner uh he yawned as he did it
though of course it must have taken some
effort or Jenny always cost something
and so they're they're talking about
this and
um he says I'm giving the node
maintainers a break every micro Shake I
settle eases the burden on them cyan
knows of the node M maintainers of
course as the Imperial roads link the
form of vassals of the old Empire with
yenes so do the nodes connect farflung
Quant with the fulcrum to extend its
protections as far as possible all over
the continent at whatever points the
senior origens have determined it best
for manipulating nearby faults or
hotpots there is an outpost within that
Outpost is is stationed a fulcrum
trained origin whose sole task is to
keep the local area stable in the
equatorial the nodes zones of protection
overlap so there's naria twitch this and
The fulcrum's Presence at its core is
why you Menace can build as it does
beyond the equatorial though the zones
are space to provide the greatest
protection for the largest population
and there are gaps in the net it's just
not worthwhile at least not according to
the fulcrum seniors to put nodes near
every little farming or mining com in
the Hinterlands
people in these places fend for
themselves as best as they can cyan
doesn't know any of the poor fools
assigned to such tedious duty but she's
very very glad no one has ever suggested
it for her it's the sort of thing they
give to origens who will never make it
to Fourth ring the ones who have lots of
raw power and little control at least
they can save lives even if they're
doomed to spend their own lives in
relative isolation and
obscurity and then she says maybe you
should leave the micros to the node
maintainers Earth knows they probably
need something to keep them from dying
of boredom so what we have here is a a
picture in her head which is going to be
dispelled shortly that these node
maintainers are you know basically the
equivalent in the the old days we'd say
like you're going to be stationed uh at
an Army Post in Alaska there's just
nothing around it's boring as hell but
you've got a job to do or it's sort of
like being a forest ranger up in a fire
tower just looking out every day to see
if there's fires and then doing
something about it directing people
there except in this case they don't
they don't have to like call somebody to
put out the fires they put out the fires
themselves they prevent the earthquakes
they prevent the slippages all all these
sorts of
matters the true nature of the node
maintainers is rather horrific as we
find out
so they they go in into one of the uh
nodes and they find the node maintainer
in a chair he's seated in it and we we
find out um the body in the node
maintainer chair is small and naked thin
its limbs atrophied hairless there are
things tubes and pipes and things she
has no words for it going into the stick
arms down the goggle throat across the
narrow crotch there's a flexible bag on
the Corpse's belly attached to its belly
somehow and full of uh the bag needs to
be changed she focuses on all this all
the little details because it helps
because there's a part of her that's
gibbering and the only way she can keep
that part internal and Silent is to
concentrate on everything she's seeing
ingenious really what they've done she
didn't know it was possible to keep a
body alive like this immobile unwilling
indefinite so she concentrates on
figuring out how they've done it the
wire framework is a particular bit of
Genius there's a crank and a handle
nearby so the whole apparatus can be
flipped over to facilitate cleaning the
wire minimizes bed sores maybe there's a
stench of sickness in the air but nearby
is a whole shelf of bottled tinctures
and pills understandable because it
would take better antibiotics than
ordinary commade penicillin to do
something like this perhaps one of the
TU things is for putting that medicine
into the node maintainer and this one is
for pushing in food and this is for
taking away urine and that cloth
wrapping is for soing up droel she sees
the bigger picture too the node
maintainer a child kept like this for
what what must have been months or Years
A Child whose skin is almost as dark as
Alabaster and whose feature might be a
perfect match for his if they weren't so
skeletal what is it's all she can
say sometimes a Roga can't learn
control now she understands that his use
of the slur is deliberate a dehumanizing
word for someone who has been made into
a thing it helps sometimes the Guardians
catch a feral who's too old to train but
young enough that killing's a waste and
sometimes they notice someone in the
grit pool one of the especially
sensitive ones who can't seem to master
control the fulcrum tries to teach them
for a while but that if the children
don't develop at a pace the Guardians
think is appropriate mother Sands can
always find another use for them and
then she says as this underf fires
Alabaster I know children who are taken
off to the nodes I didn't this
doesn't Alabaster unstiffen she hadn't
realized how stiff he was holding
himself until he bends enough to slide a
hand under the boy's neck lifting his
oversized head and turning it a little
you should see
this she doesn't want to but she looks
anyway there across the back of the
child's shaved head is a long Vining K
coloed scar embellished with the dos of
long pulled stitches it's just at the
juncture of skull and spine Roga cpen
are larger and more complex than those
of normal people when she's seen enough
Alabaster drops the child's head it's a
simple matter to apply Aion here and
there that sever the rog's self-control
completely while still allowing for its
instinctive use assuming the Roga
survives the
operation ingenious yes a newborn origin
can stop an earthshake it's an inborn
thing more certain than a child's
ability to suckle and it's this ability
that gets more origin children killed
than anything else the best of their
kind reveal themselves long before
they're old enough to understand the
danger but to reduce a child to nothing
but that instinct nothing but the
ability to quell
shakes so he goes on and what do we find
um many of these are actually
alabaster's own
children so there's this you know
horrific
sacrificial we we could call it
utilitarian in a certain way aspect to
maintaining control over the Earth that
would otherwise be constantly in flocks
and creating more and more dangers to
human life and this is what they're
taking human beings who they dehumanize
treat as mere objects into these tools
they turn um well think about
Aristotle's dicum of the slave as a
insold tool that is what is happening
here there's other things that we should
say about this this world and it it is
becoming you know not just a broken
Earth at one point in time but in the
rest of the story part of the fifth
season and the rest of the the trilogy
the obelis gate and the stone sky are in
the the fifth season where the world now
has been genuinely shaken up and comms
are on their own and UMES has been
effectively destroyed along with so many
other big cities and the question is
what are these people going to do how
are they going to survive and we find
all sorts of different models for how
this takes place there's one Comm that
attempts to dominate and take over all
the others as it's going to turn out
that one is going to be destroyed in a a
way that we'll talk about that has to do
with the
obelisks um you know another is one
where Rogas origens are actually welcome
and at least part of the time and uh
it's within a gigantic geode which
requires Origins to make it act make it
function over time to you know uh keep
it stable and and keep the air flowing
and all of that there's uh yet others
where um you know
the Guardians at least some of them are
gathering and have their own uh origin
charges we have all sorts of interesting
configurations but the key to all of
them is survival and so I think that
gives you a good picture of this world
that we're entering into there is one
other thing that we do need to talk
about before you know looking at jeon's
bio some of the interviews and then
philosophical themes and that is how the
narrative itself is
structured one of the matters that we do
need to explore from a what appears to
be purely
literary set of preoccupations but I I
think are arguably also philosophical as
well is the narrative structure the way
in which gemson is telling this
incredibly intricate and quite literally
glob mobal story that we find in the
broken Earth Trilogy and so we should
begin with the fifth season where there
are three let's call them point of view
characters and we're going to get more
as time goes on with the other stories
and what's really peculiar about this is
that and here here I'm going to give you
a spoiler uh so forgive me if you
haven't read the text there are three
women well one is actually a girl and
after we get through the prologue that
I've already mention we'll talk about
who's actually talking in the
prologue we get introduced to one of
them Asun right who is 42 years old um
her son has been killed by her husband
her daughter has been taken as well and
the world is beginning to fall apart for
her and and everybody else because the
the season is upon them um and she is
one of the main point of view characters
it begins in chapter one you are she she
is you you are essun remember the woman
whose son is dead you are an origene
who's been living in the little nothing
town of Tio for 10 years only three
people here know what you are and two of
them you gave birth to well one left who
knows now for the past 10 years you've
lived as ordinary a life as possible you
came to Tio from elsewhere and it goes
on from there and that essun is one of
the main characters throughout the
entire story and notice that it is
second person right and this is
something that Json chose to do um
knowing full well that quite
often uh you know second person is not
viewed as an appropriate way to present
things and you know third person first
person were more uh accustomed to that
then in chapter two we get another
character reads this way the straw is so
warm that damaya doesn't want to come
out of it like a blanket she thinks
through the blurriness of half sleep uh
years ago and before she died M dear
worked for the brever militia as a
seamstress and got to keep the scraps
from any repairs that required new cloth
the blanket she made for demaya was
modeled in dark um as is talking about
her her grandmother and what ends up
happening is demaya is taken by this
person who she thinks is is probably you
know a child buyer right and it turns
out that he is going to be a very
important character uh her guardian
right what strikes demaya most are the
child buyer's eyes they're white or
nearly so she can see the whites of his
eyes and then a silvery gray disc of
color she can barely distinguish from
the white even up
close um and he he tells her you know
that I'm your guardian and he is going
to introduce himself as shafa guardian
warrant so now we've got a second
character right and this little girl is
being taken away shafa will explain what
a guardian is he's taking her to the
fulcrum because she's an an origine so
we've got two different origin
characters here and then we're going to
get uh in the next
one
um this is uh a little bit later on a
third important character who is going
to be mentioned uh we have a bit more of
uh Esson and here we go in chapter four
entitled cyanate cut and Polished this
is cyanite thanks between in the
shield of her Pleasant smile she doesn't
let the affront show on her face nor
does she shift even minutely in the
chair her hands for fingers ringed
respectively in plain bands of Carnelian
white opal golden onx rest on her knees
there out a sight below the edge of the
desk um and Sayan is is uh you know
being commissioned to do something and
she's going to be assigned a mentor who
turns out that she's actually supposed
to produce children with as well and so
she is from the fulcrum and it looks
like we have three different distinct
characters going on two of which are
talked about in the third person one of
which is talked about in the second
person and the big spoiler of course is
that they are all the same human being
just at different points in the story um
so the first girl becomes the uh young
woman who's you in in her Powers meeting
Alabaster uh who then becomes Essen
who's going to be the main uh let's say
Consolidated character of these three
throughout the other two
novels now in the second novel The
obelis Gate we continue with the second
person
narration and uh it's now Essen who is
involved in all these things but we get
two other really important points of
view as well one is her daughter nasun
right and it begins first by saying I'm
telling this wrong after all a person is
herself and others relationships chisel
the final shape of one's being I am me
and you you Deana was herself and the
family that rejected her and the people
of the fulcrum who chiseled her to a
fine point cyanite was Alabaster and
enan and the people of poor lost i and m
of now you are Tio and the ashtron world
roads Walkers and your dead children and
also the living one who remains whom you
will get back that's not a spoiler you
are Essen after all you know this
already don't you nasun next then nasun
who is just eight years old when the
world ends and it says you know we can
speculate about her and then it begins
you know narrating her
story and she's going to become a major
character throughout this book The the
obelis gate and the stone sky as a
matter of fact she and her mother are
going to strive for control over the
obelisks and decide what to do with this
vast power as it turns out that they
possess and then we also get the
guardian shafa who is going to be
eventually connecting with nasun and
working with
her so here's another chapter yes you
are him too or you were until after MAV
but now he is someone else the force
that shatters the the clu is orig
applied to air goes on shafa knows
what's coming the instant he feels the
Obelisk pulse he is old old cites
Guardian he's so old he knows what stone
eaters do to powerful Origins whenever
they get the chance and he knows why it
is crucial to keep origin's eyes on the
ground and not the sky he's seen what
happens when a forringer that's how he
still thinks of cyanite connects to an
obelisk he does genuinely care about her
you realize it isn't all about control
she's his little one and he's protected
her in more ways than he knows and what
what ends up
happening is he doesn't die but part of
him is
damaged there's nothing in his lungs the
ear has been beaten out of him he's
trying not to inhale water he has so
much to do but he's only human mostly
and the terrible pressure grows and
spots of Blackness and crouch on his
vision and his whole body grows numb
with the weight of the water and he
cannot help sucking in a mighty lungful
he
panics um and then he there's something
that says to him if you wish to live
that can be arranged oh evil Earth more
offers promises suggestions and their
rewards shafa can have more power power
enough to fight the current the pain the
lack of oxygen he can live for a price
something Burns at the back of shafa's
skull we all do what we have to do comes
the seducers whisper and the cold
presence takes him
shafa can no longer remember everything
he's become damaged he's inthrall to the
evil Earth but he resists and he becomes
a major point of view as well in until
he and Nason come together and then
their stories effectively merge now in
the stone
Sky we get another incredibly important
point of view and the beginning of it
kind of gives this away right uh it it
starts the time grows short my love
let's end with the beginning of the
world shall we we shall it's strange
though my memories are like insects
fossilized in Amber and he goes on and
he says um in these memories I was
someone else just as the Stillness was
some World else then and now you and you
and who is this this is actually HOA the
stone eater who will become attached to
Essen who is in love with her eventually
and we find out that the stone eaters
were originally human beings
transformed into stone
by what they they did to the Earth
including taking away its Moon and um he
says that I'm going to tell you the
story of Sil angust I'm going to let you
know what happened a City built Wrong by
your standards and he talks about
himself as a boy staring through the
window at the Winking flowers a young
man really superficially mature in an
age sort of way yes this boy is me I
don't truly remember his name but I
remember that it had too many letters
let's call him
H the same sound just packed with all
manner of silent letters and hidden
meanings and he goes on and he says that
um the apocalypse is a relative thing
when the earth shatters it's a disaster
to the life that depends on it but
nothing much to Father earth when a man
dies it should be devastating to a girl
who once called him father mother but
this becomes as nothing when she has
been called Monster so many times she
finally Embraces the label this is
talking about nasun right and he goes on
and he says I will tell you the way that
the world s onast ended I will tell you
how I ended it or at least enough of it
that it had to start over and rebuild it
from scratch I will tell you how how I
opened the gate and flung away the Moon
and smiled as I did it so he goes on and
says I will tell you everything of how
later is the quiet of death descended I
whispered right now right now and the
Earth whispered back
burn so we get HOA the stone eater as a
point of view character now as well and
he's the one who tells the story of the
past and um essun is by the very end of
it going to be turned into a stone eater
herself and it turns out that the
narrative framework for the entire set
of novels is HOA after essen's
transformation after the world has been
essentially
saved telling the story back to her and
we are we are in on the story telling so
that's that's the narrative structure uh
quite imaginative quite Innovative isn't
it it's often Illuminating to get an
author's own words their own point a
view on the works that they spent so
much time developing as well as other
topics and so I think it can be quite
useful for us to look at some of gems's
recent interviews particularly those
that are talking about the uh broken
World trilogy but you know some other
things as well so I want to begin with
an interview from Lightspeed which we're
going to look at a little bit of and
then come back to a bit later so she's
asked tell us a bit about uh what some
of the books were that really got you
interested in fantasy and science
fiction and jemson interestingly says I
was a giant fan of tanith
Lee of Octavia Butler of Cs fredman kind
of all over the place in terms of my
interests but I've also mentioned in
other interviews that I read a lot of
Mythology especially as a child
and as a teenager and then she's asked
to follow up how about those authors you
mentioned what are some of the things
about their work that really Drew you to
them so she says I like the way that
tanith Lee played with
conceptualizations of Good and Evil and
also the way in which in a lot of her
work she emulated that sort of ancient
epic style so for example with the kns
master death's master I can't remember
what that series is called
but it felt very oral tradition recorded
on paper even though you knew that she'd
made it up but she was able to capture
the feel of stories that have been
passed out and stories that had grown
apocryphal with retelling and things
like that I like the way that she played
with the concept of who the hero was you
started off with I think Azar is the
first book's protagonist who's a
terrible person well a terrible God over
the course of the story you started to
see so much more complexity to them then
with Octavia
Butler I like the darkness of her
science fiction the fact that she really
just did not pull any punches when it
came to really depicting not just
scientific implications if aliens showed
up not just depicting the way that the
world would change but depicting the way
that people would react to those changes
which was something I really had not
seen a lot of in science fiction to the
point that I started reading her you see
the usual Science Fiction it's Star Trek
we're all going to go boldly go and meet
these aliens and we'll get along with
them relatively well or we might shoot a
few but for the most part we'll have a
decent
relationship really no discussion of
what about us are we going to get
ourselves together in order to meet
these other peoples and Butler's take on
that was H maybe with a whole lot of
mess in the way and I love the fact that
she did not pull punches on that that
was refreshing for me at the point that
I encountered her so I think this is
very interesting and revealing isn't it
showing you where she's drawing from
then in the Clark's World interview
magazine where she's published as well
she's asked about one of the main
characters much of essen's Journey is
told in the second person something
we've talked about a little bit already
what made you choose this perspective
she says well there's a couple of
reasons one of which will not become
clear until probably the third book of
the trilogy so that piece I can't talk
about but the other piece is simply that
I wanted something that felt
simultaneously distant and intimate I
wanted readers to identify with essun
and second person actually
interferes with that
identification when you play a video
game you're effectively acting out sex
person but you're reminded at every turn
that this is not you because you see a
Sprite on the screen it's similar for a
book you're reminded at every turn that
this character's name is Essen that this
character's interests and thoughts and
beliefs and feelings are not yours
naturally the tendency is to resist
identifying with her but if you're
watching someone go through hell and
she's asking you to identify with her
via that voice you have a choice you can
reject it or
empathize so that's a very interesting
point too there's a
deliberate let's say motive behind this
use of the second person this very
unusual writing
style then we uh she's asked again the
various plot threads and perspective
characters throughout the fifth season
reveal societies that Harbor fear and
Prejudice especially for the orogens
people who can manipulate the Earth how
does fear play a part in
oppression and Butler says oppression is
all about fear it's about Greed for what
other people have and finding reasons
and creating a framework to make it okay
to take what they have whether what they
have is their land or their lives that's
what it comes down to the systems that
help to maintain oppression are all
about avoiding payback for that there's
this ongoing fear on the part of those
who have incurred some kind of great
karmic debt to get what other people
have they're going to have a comeuppence
in Western culture that's the case
Western culture is all binary and about
Good and Evil and retribution and things
like that I haven't studied other
cultures as much as my own but I do see
a lot of fear even in other cultures
experiences of
Oppression possibly that's because we
deal with Western oppression globally
even though it takes different forms and
moves through different lenses even when
looking at
historical uh examples of Oppression I
see bent around making sure the people
who've had something taken from them
continue to feel like it's right to have
these things
stolen then uh electric
lit one of the joys of reading the fifth
season was the way it was structured
seeing the ways in which the different
subplots came together they're told in
different ways including in the third
and second person how did you end up
deciding to structure it in this
particular way so following up on that
um narrative
uh perspective question gemson says I
read pretty widely not just fantasy so I
don't feel particularly wedded to the
genre conventions fortunately my
Publishers has been supportive in
letting me explore and my readers have
been supportive in buying these books so
I can continue to explore I think that's
because the fantasy audience is not just
interested in formula as I think a lot
of popular wisdom would have people
believe the experimental stuff that I've
done is not that different from what a
lot of the great and enduring novels in
the genre have done and things that end
up changing the genre have done I don't
think of it as being particularly
unusual the second person piece I don't
know where that came from I often write
test chapters when I'm first starting
the novel when I'm playing with a
character and trying to figure out what
a voice or his voice is going to be I
wrote a test chapter in the second
person on a whim and it worked and I
decided to keep doing it there's no no
explanation beyond that it was really
interested because second person
generally doesn't sell too well and a
lot of readers are sort of hinky about
it so I guess we'll see and then they
change topic we get a sense of some of
the communities and internal politics of
the Stillness over the course of the
fifth season did that generally come up
as you were writing it or was there a
reference that you had figured out ahead
of time in NK gemson says both the
necessity of keeping track of little
bits of culture and world and so forth I
experimented with using a personal Wiki
and things like that before in this case
I just wrote a crap ton of notes I have
a list of all the seasons I have a list
of the glossery terms that became the
glossery I always have to keep track of
the various madeup words that I use I
made a map I'm not a map girl I don't
like Maps I'm apparently Infamous within
the genre for being bizarrely hateful on
maps but finally I had to make a map I
had to know what the geography would
look like and I needed to know what the
fault lines were and things like that I
wanted to show a society that was shaped
by its environment and was shaped by the
disasters that preceded it as I was
working on these things the rest of the
world just started to gel it was kind of
necessary because I needed a societal
structure within which these things
would happen and the societal structure
needed to show all that history that I
had built in I wanted to show a society
that was shaped by its environment and
that was shaped by the disasters that
had preceded it all of that came out of
me thinking this is is a society that
periodically loses power loses water and
where it's very difficult to maintain
central control the society would not be
topped down authoritarian except on a
superficial level local control would be
crucial they would have structures in
place to cause each Community to close
within itself and become its own
enclosed self-supporting world for a
while so all that went into figuring out
how the society worked they abandoned
capitalism during the season
because they know that's a danger it's a
great way to end up with part of your
population starving and the community
doesn't have enough people to survive
and eat and then you die so they turned
to a kind of Hardcore communist for a
brief period of time or authoritarian
totalitarian for a period of
time the flexibility of the society is
something I had to put together and the
rigidity of it was also there it needed
to be visible too I just played around
with it and then we learn more about her
World building that's really quite
interesting when she's asked this
question the structure of different
characters names is also interesting the
way that the significance of them became
apparent over the course of the novel
then gemson says well that's standard
fantasy genre stuff World building is a
central tenant within any secondary
World fantasy reference to Jr tolken um
uh on fairy stories and and uh of course
Ursula K Len from elfland to Ty Kipsy uh
working off of that this notion of
secondary creation and secondary worlds
so she she goes on and says the
readership expects and demands that
level of detail there are people who
will make role playing games in a
heartbeat out of your books and if you
haven't provided them with predictable
structures and things like that they are
going to get really pissed at you and
that can be helpful because it makes you
drill down to a level of ver similitude
that most people don't want to think
about that can create a world world I
love this phrase with a really great
lived in feel if you do it right of
course it can also be a crutch because
you're still obsessed with creating
mechanistic magic systems which is
almost an oxymoron that can be played as
a Dungeons and Dragons game you forget
it's magic it's not supposed to be make
sense it's a balancing
line then she's asked again the the fact
that manipulation of fault lines in the
novel also involves lowering the
temperature because of how energy inv is
involved struck me as very interesting
and resonant detail and gemson says the
idea was that I wasn't going to use the
word magic now that's going to change in
the later novels right but she goes on
and says why would they call it that why
would they treat it as something
different from the way their world works
it's the laws of physics there it's
science for them so they use scientific
terminology they quantify to whatever
degree they can they treat it
mechanistically they train
mechanistically they do everything they
can to systematize it it's not
systematized and they recognize that
past a certain point but that won't stop
them from continuing to try to explore
and understand it any more than not
understanding How the Universe was
created has stopped us from trying to
figure out the age of that star over
there and that sort of thing in this
case I'm doing a secondary World whose
people don't need to emulate myths
they're creating their own they are
living their own myths this is The Iliad
that they're going through and then some
stuff that's what I was trying to come
up with for the people who are living
through the impossible it isn't
impossible because they're living
through it I wanted it to feel like that
finally she's asked another really
interesting question over the course of
this book Esson has to make some
incredibly horrific decisions and is
still capable of doing horrific things
to people how do you balance making her
relatable while still making her a
complex figure jemson says I don't know
yet now this is of course before she
writes the other books my hope is that
because I'm exploring her in full I'm
delving as deeply as possible into her
you're seeing why she makes these
horrific decisions for me that's always
been a thing that helps we're dealing
with a literary landscape in which women
have to be likable to be popular but I'm
not necessarily going for popular I'm
going for keep my career alive I don't
need to be a bestseller I'd like to be
but I don't need to be I know that in a
lot of cases women characters are
expected to be nice or to be likable and
I know that I'm not going to be able to
keep ESS and likable because she's not
in a likable situation and she's got to
make horrible choices as you said so all
I can do is show that there are reasons
for those choices and those choices take
a toll she's not doing it out of
callousness or cruelty she's doing it
because she's backed into a literal
Corner in some cases and all that is
taken in some cases from Real World
events light speed interview we pick up
again she's asked we mentioned that the
series was called the broken Earth this
novel is called the fifth season do you
want to explain what these titles mean
and she says the broken Earth Trilogy is
something I literally just came up with
I told you I'm bad at naming I was
trying to think of a name for the series
my editor asked for a compl complete
synopsis and I was like something about
rocks Earth Stones broken Stones no that
doesn't sound right and that's how I
came up with that with the fifth season
though it's the name of of a phenomenon
that occurs in this world the fifth
season is set in a world which for
various reasons every few years or so
there's an extinction level event and
she goes on and explains what they they
could be this is a society that's at one
point a globe spanning Society but they
developed a system of preparing
themselves for these events which they
call fifth seasons in that system
whenever a season is declared whenever
they notice hey the sun hasn't come out
for like 3 months and we're starving
they declare seasonal law and every
small community turns itself into a
self-sufficient Survivor community and
they store massive amounts of food
against that eventuality that this will
happen they build walls they keep your
their population small and they separate
themselves into groups of essentially
casts based on
usefulness then she's asked uh do you
want to talk about the magic system in
this world and she says basically
there's people in this world that have
the ability to control seismic energy
they can trigger earthquakes it can stop
earthquakes it can shut down a volcano
Channel all that heat into water
something else they're tremendously
useful in this world but the catches
they use energy to do these things and
when there's already an earthquake or
volcano going off they can use the
energy of that when there's nothing
happening though they drag energy from
the ambient from everything around them
including the Heat and kinetic motion of
living things so they kill a lot of
people they're called origens and this
is a fantasy mutilation of a real word
the science of orogenesis or orogen is
the processes through which mountains
are created thought it was a cool word
so let's turn it into a fantasy
word so she goes on so these Origins
have this ability there's more Magical
elements to the story than the origins
but the story focus on uh focuses on
origens and how they're treated by their
society which both values and is
terrified of them and tries to control
them it does so in a lot of cases by
essentially enslaving them but other
pieces are the story of these Giant
obelis floating around in the sky nobody
really knows why but they're Big Shiny
gemstones that seem to be flickering in
and out of
reality um there's also a non-human race
in this which is my attempt to take the
idea of the mythological creatures you
see in a lot of FY and create a set of
mythological creatures from scratch
instead of making elves or dwarves or
whatever else we're used to seeing I
wanted to create something new these
creatures are called Stone eaters and
they look like statues like very
realistic classical statues human
features and so forth but they're alive
and they can Transit through Stone and
they can do a lot more than that but I
don't want to get into
spoilers then um she's asked this and I
think this is very uh good question to
to bring up particularly you know given
the possibility of uh thinking about
other similar uh stuff so uh we get um
you mentioned a lot of the novel first
novel focuses on the way origines are
treated by their society and they have
this kind of magical Academy called the
fulcrum and I was wondering if you could
talk about obviously there's magicals in
Harry Potter and earthy could you say a
bit more about how the fulcrum compares
to the magic schools we see in other
kinds of fantasy now this is an amazing
answer it's evil jamson says that's the
simplest okay I don't want to get
simplistic and binary here and talk
about Good and Evil but it is very much
a part of the system of Oppression that
they're put in place origines are not
permitted to exist unless they are
products of this fulcrum and I will go
along here and just sort of point out
that I'm a great giant BioWare Mass
Effect and Dragon Age fan and I will say
that this was probably influence I
didn't realize until I was halfway
through the first book but this is
influenced by dragon Ages Mages and Mage
circles there's other places in fantasy
and science fiction where I've seen
similar systems put in place but in this
case it's small children or basically
anyone before their teens if they're
caught and found To Be An Origin at that
point it's an essentially random thing
just pops up in the populace wherever
someone has this ability they lock up
with it or unlock up with it whatever
you want to call it and a group of
people called Guardians will come and
get them and take them to the fulcrum at
the fulcrum they learn how to control
their ability if they learned how to
control it well enough then they become
Imperial Origins and they're dispatched
to various places on the continent to
seal volcano and help Dave off the
coming of the next Fifth Season they're
trusted to do this because they've
learned how to control their
power um they'll never kill anybody by
accident that sort of thing but if they
don't learn it well enough they're
simply killed the system cannot abide
those who are not good at learning or
those who are not obedient and so it's
how a lot of systems of Oppression work
it's also inspired partly you probably
heard reservation schools in schools to
which indigenous people on multiple
continents not just a North American
thing but also Australian and so forth
where the children of indigenous people
were snatched away and sent to these
places where they weren't permitted to
use their own language and they are
forced to acculturate to White Society
because it almost always happened in
European colonized places forced to
acculturate on pain of death and in some
cases well it wasn't overtly said it was
on pain of death but an actual
practicality a lot of kids died in those
schools so there were a lot of
influences in this but I I was thinking
about the ways in which oppression tends
to work it's not always a case of an
evil Overlord coming in and saying I'm
going to make you my slave in a lot of
cases you've got people complicit in the
system who are part of it themselves the
fulcrum is run by Origins and you see
it's not a kind or gentle Place despite
that fantasy literature interview moving
on um Kevin way says let me say congrats
on your recent Hugo win uh we wanted to
start off by talking about how you write
I know you've said in the past your
writing process differs depending on
what you write has the way you've
written broken Earth differed
significantly from the way you've
written other works was there a large
difference between the writing processes
for the fifth season and the second book
The Obelisk gate Jemison says my process
is still pretty much the same at the
planning stage I outline and will'll put
together different sets of information
storage like at one point I used to use
a Wiki now I just write notes I've got a
file that's nothing more than Stone lore
I've made up and another file that keeps
track of all the seasons file that keeps
track of the way the plate tectonics
would have moved over the years but I
think the difference now that I'm
writing book three of the trilogy is I
am now completely off the outline I've
been pancing it almost exclusively which
is not normal for me and I'm not sure
what that's going to mean I think it's
mostly that I'm working at speed right
now and I'm working at such speed I
don't have time to even slow down to
check my outline and make sure I'm track
it's a fairly simple story at this point
all the play settings have been moved
and the chessboard is all set up now
it's just a matter of now fight then
they say that sounds very exciting I
know you've said you needed a big break
a bit of pallet cleanser after book one
due to how dark the world of the
Stillness is do you need another one in
between books two and three and jemson
says well I did take one but it wasn't a
big break it was like a couple months
and I didn't need it in the same way
really what I think is I've finally
gotten used to the bleakness of the
world also it's okay when you're doing
something about the horror it feels
easier than if you were just wallowing
in it then she's asked um let's talk
about your most recent work the obelis
gate there's a moment when nasun
realizes her father's turned completely
against her and you wrote that that her
heart breaks in this moment another
small quiet tragedy amid so many others
it is a manipulation and from now on all
her acts of affection will be calculated
performative I thought this was a really
tragic moment how is the reader supposed
to feel about this Json says well I I
think it's telegraphed in the text that
it's a tragedy that it is the nature of
of abuse and certain types of Oppression
that they force kids of certain types to
grow up faster than they would
necessarily than or then they should
this is the harm that's done by it this
it damages you literally from childhood
up and she says it's a common thing for
origene children they all have that
moment you see multiple children
throughout the Obelisk gate and you see
the ways in which they're all scarred
sometimes overtly sometimes more
symbolically but they're all scarred
realizing that the people in their lives
can't be trusted and hate them and will
turn on them she goes on again she's
asked about um you know concealment
about hiding and she
says I think what I'm getting at there
is this phenomenon especially among
African-Americans but you see it among
other races where it's possible of
passing I'm really just touching on the
fact that people who are capable of
passing are not wrong if you've got a
choice between living and someone trying
to kill you and people sending you off
to an abusive school and all the
horrible things that happened to you it
makes perfect sense to avoid that the
catch is that people who couldn't avoid
it will hate you and they will have that
resentment to towards you because you
didn't suffer something they suffered
you suffered something different and
that's the recognition that Essen
doesn't ever get which is that it must
have been hard for cutter to hide
himself to constantly worry about
Discovery all of that must have been its
own hell but she's not there all she's
thinking about what she suffered as the
main hell I was just really touching on
that it's hypocritical but Essen came to
that after a full lifetime of finding
herself and getting herself together
imagine having to hide as a child when
you don't even know what you're hiding
from and you don't know yourself it does
a lot more damage than she thinks it
does then uh she's asked um about HOA
the the uh uh Stone Eater character who
we get introduced to uh early on in uh
the oblas
gate and
um she's asked there are these parts of
the story where ho is narrating in first
person you've discussed in the past why
you chose second person and how you
wrote The Fifth Season to make us feel
sympathetic towards Essen are these
first person sections with ho meant to
do something similar and she
says to draw people closer to him no if
if people by book two haven't started to
engage with HOA uh then they're not
going to all I wanted to do is
illuminate that he's a person which I
think I did by depicting him as a flesh
and blood person before revealing his
true self he's not as enigmatic feeling
or I hope he's not as an enigmatic
feeling as the other Stone eaters but
they're all the same I want people to
think they've all got stories they're
all in the eye of a tale somewhere and
she says he's pretty human anyway a lot
of the things I'm I'm trying to do in
this story is get past people's initial
Impressions readers as well as the
characters I talked about this in one of
my blog posts about how with Essen she's
a middle-aged woman she's what we would
call Black she's violent tempered she's
got PTSD that manifest is wiping out
cities every once in a while she does
horrible things over the course of the
story a lot of people are going to look
at that on a superficial level and
immediately be immediately be like I'm
not interested in this character I can't
identify with this character so this is
why with the first book I took people
through showing how she became what she
is and hopefully getting people to
identify with the
character same with HOA ho is terrifying
when you really think about it creepy
he's supposed to be but on the other
hand in book three in particular we're
going to see how HOA became what he is
so you know he's still going to be
creepy but on the other hand you may
understand him and you may be able to
empathize with him if people can
empathize with the average character in
fantasy they should be able to empathize
with a character like HOA there's no
reason why they shouldn't be it's just a
matter of how well I manage to bring in
a
cross then she says a little bit later
what I think to some degree what I'm
trying to engage with is that fantasy
tendency to try and justify oppression
you see it all again and again in
fantasy that this one group of people
over here are mistreated but there's a
good reason for it as in the obelis gate
as in Drag age they're mistreated but
it's because they're actually dangerous
and I wanted to interrogate that in my
series the reasoning is that the
origines are more dangerous than other
people because boom but throughout the
story you see evidence that there's
different responses people could have
from that one of the responses they
could have is snatch them away from
their parents kill them if they get out
of control shove them into this terrible
place where they're forced to learn how
to control themselves the fulcrum the
other is to leave leave them with their
origy parents so they learn from people
who love them and have the skill to help
them don't traumatize them there's a lot
of different responses people could have
to realizing you've got this group of
people among you that's different you
could accommodate that difference you
could find a way to wrap your society
around that difference and make it
healthier and safer for everybody
instead of shoving some into a horrible
place or genociding them what I want to
keep what I keep wanting to show is that
people think that the idea that a group
of people is legitimately different and
therefore it's legitimately okay to
discriminate against them this is not
really the question that should be being
asked the question that should be being
asked is why aren't you more willing to
accept these people's
difference going on to the Paris review
interview um she's asked what are the
pasts you draw upon and the Futures you
want to see jeson says
the pasts that I draw upon tend to be
Mythic pasts I'm not super interested in
writing historical fantasy I've done
that a few times in the case of subject
areas I felt should have been explored
more like the Haitian revolution for
example but for the most part I'm more
interested in exploring the gods we
could have had or these are the creation
myths that we could have explored I'm
not super interested in existing
mythology though existing mythology does
inform just about everything I'm coming
up with but that's more along the lines
of this is how mythology should be
structured so you need to look at
existing mythology to understand that if
I'm trying to come up with a secondary
world the goal is not to use too much of
the existing world I tend to prefer
secondary worlds to the existing one and
she says if I'm writing a novel set in
New York City in the modern day I've got
to research every little detail mostly
because my friends all live here and
will give me all kinds of grief if I get
it wrong it's a lot easier right in the
secondary world you don't have to do as
much research you can wing it a little
bit more and she goes on and says
science fiction has always said it
strives for a future for all humankind
most science fiction does not depict
futures for all humankind though in a
lot of cases when it tries to do so it
does this by a kind of hand waving we
get to those Shiny Happy utopian Futures
Star Trek for example in Star Trek in
the future everybody can be part of the
Starfleet supposedly all of humanity has
access to good education good food all
that other stuff and yet Starfleet is
still dominated by middle class middle
American white dudes so something
happened along the way clearly there's
only one Asian man and Asian people
represent the bulk of humanity now
that's crazy just talking about the
original series there right and then uh
she's asked in an interview with Ursa
Ken she issued the label of Science
Fiction and called herself a novelist
and poet instead maybe it was how she
was feeling that day but have you ever
felt that label of science fiction is a
pigeon hole and she says no because it
hasn't been for me maybe because I'm a
black woman there's an automatic
assumption I'm somewhere in the margins
of Science Fiction in the margins of
fantasy and therefore people from
outside the genre's margins are a little
bit more willing to take a look at me
even though I'm writing solidly science
fiction stuff but the broken Earth
Series has gotten the attention that it
has in part because I tend to use
literary techniques as well and that's
just because I don't care I'll use
whatever techniques are necessary to get
the story across and I read pretty
widely so when people kept saying second
person is just not done in science
fiction I was like well they said first
person wasn't done in fantasy and I did
that with my first novel I don't
understand the weird marriage to
particular techniques and the weird
insistent that only certain things can
be done in science fiction and then she
goes on and says in a lot of cases
people read science fiction and fantasy
when they're younger and then the age
out of it fantasy in particular they get
tired of the Endless tolken clones they
get tired of stories where an alpha
dwarf and a halfling walk into a bar
they're not bad but you see the formula
and you've seen the formula a couple of
times you get tired of it there's always
people within the genre who are
perfectly happy with that formula and
they seek out that comfort food every
time they read but a lot of readers move
on I believe at least a few of my
literary readers are ex genre readers
who had left basically in a half tired
of the formula and came back because
something I'm doing speaks to something
they want there's a change that's been
happening on a number of different
levels there's more literary style
writers in the genre there's more
writers who are willing to be inclusive
whether they themselves are
representative of different races
cultures ethnicities or not I may be one
of the more visible representatives of
it but I'm not the only
one and then she's asked and this is
where we're going to end about um
Justice what do you want people to know
about Justice and she she says most of
us grew up on fairy tales in which there
was quick and fair and obvious Justice
or at least we were told it was quick
and fair and obvious at least a lot of
the fairy tales that we grew up on had
really disproportionate Justice like did
they really have to burn the wolf I
suppose they did or did they really have
to murder the witch who tried to eat the
children well she did try to eat them so
Tit for Tat a lot of the fairy tales
that have retired over time posited a
kind of Justice we no longer think of as
just we don't have good fairy tales for
the justice system we're currently
living in we've been told the police are
your friend if you did something wrong
you'll be punished if you didn't do
anything wrong the system will set you
free none of this is true this is this
is not the justice system we're living
in at least here in the United States
and if you're black then all all bets
are off I think that on some level that
is where fantasy writers and to some
degree science fiction writers tend to
be trying to create the fairy tales that
we need to survive the world is pretty
unjust right now those of us who have
grown up on the short end of the stick
understand this innately and want
acknowledgement of that reality because
so much of American society is
dedicating to weaving the illusion that
what you see is not actually what is
happening the endless excuse Mak is part
of our mythologizing these days but
fixing that is part of the job that
Science Fiction and Fantasy can do
that's one of the things that I believe
this genre is ideal for
accomplishing if it chooses to so a lot
of great stuff in these interviews a lot
of interesting themes to think about now
let's uh delve into some of these
philosophical themes in a a little bit
more
detail
one of the key and deep philosophical
themes that is running throughout the
entire broken Earth Trilogy and indeed
throughout a lot of gems's Works we're
actually going to reference a short
story from how long till black future
month uh in order to unpack this is the
let's call it the nature and the many
faceted and the
reinforcements of evil among human
beings and there's you could say it's
not just one single thing that leads
human beings to hate to exploit to fear
to dominate and these things all get
wrapped up together they take many forms
the ruptures within individual
relationships what happens over
Generations the splits within societies
themselves and we really get to see that
what's going on in this world that uh
she's
depicting has to do with a previous time
in that world before the the shattering
before the creation of the stone eaters
when human beings were living in a pan
Continental civilization
and nevertheless although they occupied
something almost like a
Utopia they couldn't get it right and
they wound up having to
engage in things that they told
themselves weren't evil but actually
were quite evil as we'll look at in a
moment but I think that it could be
quite
useful to take a a very quick look at
this first short story
in uh how long till black future month
called the ones who stay and fight and
in interviews gemson has said well this
is clearly a uh reference and response
to Ursula K Len's uh short story similar
to this uh those who walk away from omus
if you're not familiar with that you
probably want to check it out because it
is an amazing piece one that I actually
use uh to start conversation in my
ethics classes and it has to do with the
notion of a just a fair a tolerant a
fully developed society and whether some
suffering is the price of that some
suffering imposed on one who can't even
understand that and gemson has said you
know well she actually has a reference
Tois right here in this she says this is
umot and not that barbaric America this
is not omalos a tick of a city fat and
happy with its head buried in a tortured
child my accounting of umh halad is an
homage true but there's nothing for you
to fear friends so what is this city
like she talks about it on the the day
of a festival and she says joyous it is
a steady joy that fills this city easy
to speak of but most difficult to
describe accurately I see the
incredulity in your face the difficulty
Li partly in my lack of words and partly
in your lack of understanding because
you've never seen a place like um halot
and because I am myself only an observer
not yet privileged to visit and she says
how can I illuminate this it's a city
whose inhabitants simply care for one
another this is a city's purpose they
believe not merely to generate revenue
or energy or products but to shelter and
nurture the people who do these things
and then she talks about the variety the
citizens in umh halad are so many and so
wildly different in appearance and
origin and development people in this
land come from many others and it shows
in Sheen of skin and kink of hair and
plumpness of lip and hip and uh she she
goes on and she says there's history
rather than malice in the differences
and it's still being actively
intentionally corrected because the
people of umad are not naive believers
in Good Intentions as the solution to
all ills there are no worshippers of
mere tolerance here no desperate gravers
for that grudging pittance of respect
which is diversity madans are learned
enough to understand what must be done
to make the world better and pragmatic
enough to actually enact
it she goes on and she says does that
seem wrong to you it should not the
trouble is that we have a bad habit
encouraged by those concealing ill
intent of insisting that people already
suffering should be afflicted with
further unnecessary pain that is the
Paradox of Tolerance the treason of free
speech we hesitate to admit some people
are just evil and need to be stopped and
that's where she talks about barbaric
America and uh omalos and going on a
little bit further she
says um how can such a city possibly
survive let alone Thrive wealthy with no
poor advanced with no war a beautiful
place where all Souls know themselves
beautiful it cannot be you say Utopia
habal it's a fairy tale a thought
exercise crabs in a barrel Dog Eat Dog
oppression Olympics it would not last
you insist it could never be in the
first place racism is natural so natural
we will call it tribalism to insinuate
that everyone does it sexism is natural
and homophobia is natural and religious
intolerance is natural and greed is
natural and cruelty is natural and
savagery and fear and and and impossible
you hiss right and she says well clearly
I've offended you if that's your mindset
about these
matters and she goes on and she says
um umh halot has actually been a worse
place in the
past um the city had a different
civilization once one which might not
have upset you so much remnants of that
time do the land all around the city
ruined and enormous and half broken
right and she goes on and says that um
umal adans must be reminded of these
things upon coming of age and told
carefully curated stories of their
nature and purpose when the young
citizens learn this it's a shock almost
incomprehensible in that they literally
lack the words to
comprehend these things right um and
they they go on and and talk about the
descript Ive terms that they use for
themselves and then she says these are
just words friends don't you see without
the attached contempt such terms have no
more meaning than if horses could
proudly introduce themselves as Palomino
a miniature or hairy-footed
difference was never the problem in and
of itself and umans still have
differences with each other of opinion
and otherwise of course they do their
people but what shocks the young
citizens of umh halot is the realization
that once those differences of opinion
involve differences in respect that once
value was ascribed to some people and
not others that once Humanity was
acknowledged for some and not for others
and now the story changes they talk
about listening to our world on
equipment that Bridges these um
Dimensions right watching our television
following our social media right and
time flow the same in both worlds but
people there have not wasted themselves
on crushing one another into submission
and this makes a
remarkable difference and so
people listen to our stuff and then
become in a certain way
contaminated by it and so we have social
workers and the social workers go around
and find these people and what do they
do they they kill those
who indulge themselves in this this is
part of the price of having that semi
utopian society and there's a a vignette
here of a man who's get gets a pike
through the heart a very quick merciful
death and his little daughter is
standing over him and she says I'll get
back at you I'll make you die the way
you made him die this is Unthinkable
thing to say something is very wrong
here she snars how dare you how dare
dare you and they are posed with a
decision they're going to um you know
take her on and um she will be in
quarantine and if they accept the hand
listen to them they will try to explain
why her father had to die she's eager
for the knowledge but something must be
done then they will bury him with their
own hands in the beautiful garden that
they tend to it holds all the um
audience who broke the law just because
they had to die as deterrence doesn't
mean they can't be honored for this
sacrifice and then gison goes on there
is only one treatment for this toxin
once it gets into the blood tooth and
nail Spear and Claw up close and brutal
No Quarter can be given no parole no
debate the child must grow and learn and
become another social worker fighting an
endless war against an idea but she will
live and help others and Find meaning of
that if she takes the woman 's hand
right and so what do we have depicted
here uh a very different way of living
one in which difference does not produce
dehumanization very different than what
is going on in uh these these works and
I think it would be good actually to
begin sort of at the end because we find
out in the stone sky where the stone
eaters came from they were a originally
we could say the progenitors of the
origins those who are hated feared
discriminated against brought into the
fulcrum lynched
assassinated
harnessed because there was something
else going on before
that so we have this civilization right
then here's the story The Stillness in
these days is three lands not one their
names if this matters are mear kakar and
silar Sil Angus started out as part of
kakar then all of it then all of mear
too all became Sil
anagist killer to the South was at once
a small and nothing land occupied by
many small and nothing peoples one of
these groups was the thice it was hard
to say their name with the proper
pronunciation so the sil Sila uh gines
called them nce two words did not mean
the same thing but the latter is what on
the silagan took their land the niece
fought but then responded like any
living thing under threat with the
diaspora sending whatever was left of
themselves flying forth to take root and
perhaps survive where it could the
descendants of these niece became part
of every land every people blending in
among the rest and adapting to local
Customs they managed to keep hold of who
they were though continuing to speak
their own language even as they grew
fluent in other tongues they maintained
some of their old ways too and while
they lost much of the distinctive look
that came of isolation within their
small land many retained enough of it to
the so that to this day ice white eyes
and Ash Blow Hair carry a certain stigma
you see now but the thing that made the
niece truly different was their magic
magic is everywhere in the world
everyone sees it feels it flows with it
in s anagist magic is cultivated in
every flower bed and tree line and grap
Vine drapped wall every householder
business must produce its share which is
then funneled away and G engineered
Vines and pumps to become the power
source for a global civilization it is
illegal to kill in Sil anus because life
is a valuable resource the niece did not
believe this magic could not be owned
they insisted any more than life could
be and thus they wasted both by building
among many other things plutonic engines
that did nothing they were just pretti
or thought-provoking or crafted for the
G sheer Joy of crafting yet this art ran
more efficiently and powerfully than
anything the sil an Austine had ever
managed how did it begin you must
understand that fear is at the root of
such things nce people looked different
behaved differently were different but
every group is different than others
differences alone are not enough are
never enough to cause problems so anus
assimilation of the world had been over
for a century before I was ever made all
cities were s anagist all languages had
become sanagustin but there are none so
frightened or so strange In Their Fear
as
conquerors they conjure Phantoms
endlessly terrified that their victims
will someday do back what was done to
them even if in truth their victims
couldn't care less about such pettiness
and have moved on conquerors live in
dread of the day when they are shown to
be not superior but simply lucky so when
n Magic proved more efficient than
sanagustin even though nce did not use
it as a weapon this is what keni told us
perhaps it began with Whispers that
white niece irises gave them poor
eyesight and perverse inclinations and
that split nce tongues could not speak
truth that sort of sneering happens
cultural bullying but things got worse
it became easy for
Scholars to build reputations and
careers around the notion that n sesap
were fun mentally different somehow more
sensitive more active less controlled
less civilized and this was the source
of their magical peculiarity this is
what made them not the same kind of
human as everyone else eventually not as
human as everyone else finally not human
at
all once the niece were gone of course
it became clear that the fabled niece
cestin did not exist uh sing gastin
Scholars and biom magistrates had plenty
of prisoners to study but TR as they
might no discernable variance from
Ordinary People could be found this was
intolerable more than intolerable after
all if the niece were just ordinary
human beings then on what basis had
military Appropriations pedagogical
reinterpretation and entire disciplines
been
formed so what we see here is sort of an
allegory but also The Narrative of of
this world as well right an allegory for
the types of Oppression and hatred and
um reading the other as different as
being lesser as perhaps not even being
human but also as being a great threat
that has to be controlled and coralled
and what do they in fact do well they
take the uh descendants of the nce and
they harness them they turn them into
tuners they also charge the obelisks by
taking uh the niece and essentially
lobotomizing them and putting their
their life energy
into uh matrices and so we read here
this is a much later
on
um this is what the S Stines truly made
us for to affirm a philosophy life is
sacred in Sil anagist as it should be
for the city Burns life as the fuel for
its Glory there are many ways to honor
life aren't there let's pause on this
for a moment you could honor life as
something intrinsically worthwhile in
itself you could also view it as a
resource to be exploited and in the the
people that you already view as inferior
why not use their life why not harness
their dangerous magic so we go on and we
see the niece were not the the first
people chewed up in its MW just the
latest and crul extermination of many
but for a society built on
exploitation there is no greater threat
than having no one left to oppress and
now if nothing else is done sanus must
again find a way to fision its people
into subgroupings and create reasons for
conflict among them there's not enough
magic to be had just from plants and
geng engineered fauna someone must
suffer if the rest are to enjoy luxury
better the Earth cing just reasons
better to enslave a great inanimate
object that cannot feel pain and will
not object but this reasoning is still
flawed because sanist is ultimately
unsustainable it is parasitic its hunger
for magic grows with every drop it
develops it devours the earth's core is
not
Limitless eventually if it takes 50,000
years that resource will be exhausted
too and then everything dies right and
so what do we have um going on here San
just this civilization is exploiting
these people who they've marginalized
and and oppressed for generations and
generations and now they're going to tap
into the Earth itself and this is going
to generate incredible conflicts and so
we get to or we come back to the Fifth
Season there's a few sections from this
that I want to uh bring up so the
origines and the Guardians what is going
on well um we we see that uh damya is
told this interesting story by shafa her
guardian right that um the or the origin
of the Guardians is um in this this need
to control the origins and keep them
from taking power within the Empire and
so he says as the fulcrum is an order of
origines we are the order that watches
the fulcrum for as we know despite all
your terrible power you are not
Invincible you can be beaten and um she
likes the story she imagined herself as
Shem shenna the hero right bravely f
facing a terrible Foe and defeating him
with cleverness and skill with every you
and you're that shafa speaks however she
begins to understand this is a little
girl who has orogenic powers he does not
see her as a potential
chema and so we guardian's trainy
continues perhaps not noticing she's
gone
still um we train as Shem shenna did we
learn how orogenic power works and we
find ways to use this knowledge against
you we watch for those among your kind
who might become the next MMS and we
eliminate them the rest we take care of
I Am Your Guardian now and it is my duty
to make sure you remain helpful never
harmful so that tells her exactly where
she stands if she gets out of line the
Guardians will kill her uh and why is
this being done so we we learn in her
conversation well this is uh different
character who is is the same person of
course right with Alabaster the 10 Ring
origin um sanite um is told by
Alabaster um well she's talking with
with him and uh he says we could try
letting origines run things and she
laughs that would last for about 10
minutes before every Guardian in the
Stillness shows up to Lynch us with half
the continent and tow to watch and cheer
and he says they kill us because they've
got Stone L telling them at every turn
we're born evil some kind of Agents of
Father Earth monsters that barely
qualify as
human she says yes but you can't change
Stone lore Stone lore changes all the
time sanite he does not say her name
often either it gets her attention every
civilization adds to it parts that don't
matter to the people at the time are
forgotten there's a reason tablet to is
so damage someone somewhere back in time
decided it wasn't important or was wrong
and didn't bother to take care of it or
maybe they even deliberately tried to
obliterate it which is why so many of
the early copies are damaged in exactly
the same way so he goes on the archs
found some old tablets in some of the
one of the Dead cities on tapita Plateau
they'd written down their stone stone
lore too ostensibly to pass it on to
Future Generations but what was on the
tablets was different drastic Ally so
from the lore we learned in school for
all we know the admonition against
changing the lore itself is a
recent
addition and so then he he goes on he
says um or gemson goes
on it makes her not want to believe him
or maybe that's her dislike for him
surfacing again but ston lore is as old
as intelligence it's all that's allowed
humankind to survive through fifth
season after Fifth Season the lures
tells stories about what happens when
people political leaders or philosophers
or well-meaning medlers try to change
the lore disaster inevitably
results so she's questioning him and
then she says well what's actually the
case then and this is where we get to
some other important stories I also did
want to share um a little bit from the
Obelisk gate with you before that though
we should we should say something about
why the stone lore being changed changed
matters because the stone lore is a
fixed part of the culture that you know
seems to have some sort of purpose
behind it this is how you survive the
seasons and it it gives you a map of
where things are so the origins are evil
they're in League with evil father Earth
as it turns out they're actually the
opposite of that right um they're
they're not uh again they're not uh IED
with the earth the earth is their
greatest enemy um so I I did want to
bring up one other thing
so the fatherdaughter
conflict that's been brewing uh
throughout the Obelisk gate comes to a
culmination when um gah the father of
nasun um tries to attack and and kill
her and
what do we find out going here
so in this
scene right
[Music]
um he says sweetening it's the voice he
usually uses for her but she knows it
isn't real his eyes are as cold as the
ice she left all over his house a few
days ago his jaw is tied his body
shaking just a little there's a knife in
his tight fist it has a slight
iridescence that completely disguises
the razor sharpness of its napped edges
hi daddy she
says um and then she says Mama's alive
daddy if the words mean anything to him
it doesn't show he just keeps standing
there looking at her looking at her eyes
in particular she's always had her
mother's eyes suddenly it doesn't matter
nasun sigh and rubs her face with her H
her hands as weary as father Earth must
be after so many eternities of hate hate
is tiring nalism is e easier though she
doesn't know the word and will not for a
few years it is what she's feeling
regardless an overwhelming sense of the
meaninglessness of it all why that
meaninglessness because of all the
irrational though explicable hate and
Prejudice and misunderstandings getting
in the way of her own relationship with
her parent who's by the way killed her
younger brother once he discovered that
he was in
origin she says then I think I
understand why you hate us I've done bad
things daddy like you probably thought I
would I don't know how to not do them
it's like everybody wants me to be bad
so there's nothing else I can
be she hesitates then says what's been
in her mind for months now unspoken she
doesn't think she'll have another chance
to say it I wish you could love me
anyway even though I'm bad she thinks of
shafa she says this though her guardian
shafa who loves her no matter what as a
father
should and then she says to to her
father I'm sorry Daddy I tried to keep
loving you but it was too hard and he
attacks her and she transforms him into
stone although he does manage to to hit
her as well with his knife so I mean
this is a sort of one of many
demonstrations of what this
irrational hatred and fear fostered by
generations of of culture and encounters
and experiences looks like in this novel
and so this is a a good place I think
going from the sort of universal down to
the particular to to bring this
exploration of the theme of human evil
to a close and go on to think about some
others our examination of the broken
Earth Trilogy is already a little bit
overtime or let's be honest quite a bit
over time at this point but there is one
other major philosophical theme that I
think is well worth exploring and it
brings together a number of different
let's call them key agents or elements
in the
story and one of the
is the Earth itself which in the
beginning in this first book Is you know
called evil Earth and there's a story
that's being told
here according to Legend father Earth
did not originally hate life in fact as
the Loris tullet Once Upon a Time Earth
did everything he could to facilitate
the strange emergence of Life on his
surface he crafted even predictable
Seasons kept changes of wind and wave
and temperature slow enough that every
living being could adapt evolve some in
waters that purified themselves Skies
that always cleared after a storm he did
not create life but that was happen
stance but he was pleased and fascinated
by it and proud to nurture such strange
Wild Beauty upon his surface then people
began to do horrible things to Father
Earth they poison Waters Beyond even
Hill's ability to cleanse killed much of
the other life that had lived on his
surface they drilled through the crust
of his skin in past the blood of his
mantle to get at the sweet marrow of his
bones and at the height of human hubris
and might it was the origines who did
something that even Earth could not
forgive they destroyed his only child no
lorist that seanet has ever talked to
knows what this cryptic phrase means it
is in stone L just oral tradition
occasionally recorded on ephemerals like
paper and hide and too many seasons have
changed it sometimes it's a the Earth's
favorite glass knife that the origines
destroyed sometimes it's his shadow
sometimes it's most valued breeder
whatever the words mean the lists and
mests agree on what happened after the
origines committed their great sin
father Earth's shell surface cracked
like an eggshell nearly every living
thing died as his Fury became manifest
in the first and most terrible of the
fifth Seasons the shattering season
powerful as they were those ancient
people had no warning no time to build
build store catches no stone L to guide
them it is only through sheer luck that
enough of humankind survived to
replenish itself afterwards and never
has life attained the heights of power
that it once held Earth's recurrent Fury
will never allow that cyanite has always
wondered about these Tales there's a
degree of poetic license in them
primitive people trying to explain what
they didn't understand but all legends
contain a kernel of Truth maybe the
ancient Origins did shatter the planet
crust some somehow how though it's clear
now that there's more to orig than what
the fulcrum teaches and maybe there's a
reason the fulcrum doesn't teach it if
the Legends are
true but facts are facts even if somehow
every origin and existent down of the
infants could be yolked together they
could not destroy the world's surface it
would ice everything there's not enough
warmth or movement anywhere to do that
much damage they'd burn themselves out D
trying and die which means that part of
the tale can't be true or jny cannot be
to blame for the Earth's rage no not
that anyone but another Roga would
accept this
conclusion
now what was the real story well we're
going to find this out as we go
along and alabaster is going to be the
one who will say you know it was the
Moon the Moon which every once in a
while comes back was the Earth's child
and taking it away as well as drill in
into the Earth to try to suck out you
know the the power from it that is what
turned the Earth against human beings it
wasn't Rogas origens who actually did
that it was the tuners who are combining
oreni and magic in a way that both Essen
and nasen are going to be able to do as
well through now here we get another
really important element of the story
The obelisks and what is the obelisk
well it's when you connect all of these
up together these Giant floating
crystals that have incredible power that
you know Essen as sanite is able to
connect to early on in well in her story
but later on in the fifth
season it turns out that all of these
obelisks can be brought into a network
and that is actually what Essen does to
turn every single person in the Cal that
is attacking them into stone right and
it requires incredible power and it
turns out that naso is able to access
this gate as well and we're going to
have a rivalry between the two of them
over who whose vision of what to do is
going to control things so the obelisks
themselves are incredibly powerful
artifacts tools uh
repositories of life and its
possibilities
and um they are used originally by the
first tuners who are going to become the
stone
eaters to produce this cataclysm within
the Earth and it throws the Moon away as
a result and we get Alabaster telling us
some things to Essen that are quite
important so he uh says you know we we
use the obelisks to Stills their just
big strange rocks that City those
Wonders that dead Civ was run by Origins
we destroyed the world just like they
always said we did Rogas what they got
wrong are the loyalties the stories say
we're agents of Father Earth but it's
the opposite we're his enemies he hates
us more than he hates the Stills because
of what we did that's why he made the
Guardians to control us the Guardians
are also an artifact of this interplay
between human beings and father
Earth and then she says bastor you're
talking as if the planet is real alive I
mean aware all that stuff about father
Earth it's just stories to explain
what's wrong with the world like those
weird Cults that crop up from time to
time I heard of one that asks an old man
in the sky to keep them alive every time
they go to sleep people need to believe
there's more to the world than there is
and the world is just you
understand this now after two dead
children in the repeated destruction of
your life there's no need to imagine the
planet as some malevolent Force seeking
Vengeance it's a rock this is how life
is supposed to be terrible and brief and
ending if you're lucky
Oblivion so she's saying ah this is just
anthropomorphism this is what people do
and then we get the real kick in the
pants Alabaster says no actually there
is an earth that is Cent ient and living
and Incredibly powerful and there are
also these Stone eaters that are
involved in a three-sided
War right says all three sides want the
war to end it's just a question of how
we're the problem people two of the
sides are deciding what should be done
with us the phrasing explains a lot the
earth and the stone eaters no they're
people to us and haven't you figured
that out they need things want things
feel things the same way that we do and
they've been fighting this war much much
longer than you or I some of them from
the very
beginning they're over 30,000 years old
right and uh she asks well so what are
these three sides and alabaster is going
to reveal this um and he tells about
this this you know story that that he's
going into there's this war that has
been going on for a very very very long
time and the stone eaters are part of
this and you know one of the sides uh is
is about just destroying Humanity uh
another is about peaceful coexistence
right and the key to it is going to be
getting the Moon Back bringing the moon
using the Obelisk gate back for father
Earth so he says the the third faction
are those who want atuse people in
Father Earth agreeing to tolerate one
another even if it means creating the
rift and killing millions in the process
peaceful coexistence by any means
necessary
right so that's sort of their their
mission there and you know we find out a
few other interesting things the
Guardians are in fact there not just to
control the the origins but as uh agents
of Father Earth and we find that nasun
is actually able to hear father Earth uh
as they're moving down into the mantle
when the earth speaks it does not do so
in words exactly this is a thing you
know already but that Nason only learns
in this moment she sesses the meanings
here's the vibrations with the bones of
her ears shutters them out through her
skin feels them pull tears from her eyes
it is like drowning an energy sensation
and emotion it hurts remember the Earth
wants to kill her but remember too nasun
wants it just as dead so it says in
micro shapes that will eventually stir a
tsunami somewhere in the southern
hemisphere hello little enemy this is
something that the Earth says to several
people this is an approximation all that
her young mind can bear and she shouts
at the the Earth you let him go you let
him go right now about chaa the the G
Guardian the core of the world is metal
molten and yet crushed into solidity
there is some malleability to it the
surface of the red Darkness begins to
Ripple and change as Nason watches
something appears that for an instant
she cannot parse a pattern familiar a
face it is just a the suggestion of a
person eyes and a mouth shadow of a nose
but then for an instant the eyes are
distinct in shape the lips lined and
detailed a mole appearing be behind
beneath the eyes which open no one she
knows just a face where there should be
none again the Earth is able to
communicate the Earth actually talks
about obligation what was stolen or lent
must be
recompensed and then she there's another
interesting thing here Nason cannot help
but understand that within the Earth's
Embrace which is with its meaning
thrumming through her bones the silver
magic it comes from Life those who made
the obelis sought to harness magic and
they succeeded oh how they succeeded
they used it to build wonders beyond
imagining but then they wanted more
magic than just what their own lives or
the accumulated eons of life and death
on Earth's surface could provide and
they saw how much magic brimmed just
beneath that surface rif for the
taking it may have never occurred to
them that so much magic so much life
might be indicator of awareness the
Earth does not speak in words after all
and perhaps Nas soon realizes um perhaps
these Builders of the great Obelisk
Network were not used to respecting
lives different from their own not
really different from the people who run
the fulcrums or Raiders or her father so
where they should have seen a living
being they saw only another thing to
exploit where they should have asked or
left alone they raped for some crimes
there's no fitting Justice only
reparation and so we go on from that and
um what we're going to find by the end
the oblisk gate is a struggle between
nasun who's got this you know Bleak
nistic attitude and actually thinks
let's just turn everybody into stone and
end the end the the life of of
everything on the earth now and her
mother essun who is trying to do
something more human oriented let's say
in order to save her her own daughter
too uh to bring the moon back to give
father Earth back something that he has
been Desiring his missing child and to
bring about this truce and that is what
she in fact succeeds in doing and that
brings things to a
undetermined but
satisfactory resolution of sorts to this
wonderful Trilogy of works and so here
is where we end
this examination of NK gon's the broken
Earth
[Music]
trilogy